very excited because right now we do
something a little special I'm going to
bring out my guests the world's greatest
secret agent sterling Archer let's bring
him out here that's where this phone
never rings on my go yellow no Archer
you're supposed to be here on this side
no we have to do an interview you're
gonna come out here inclusion okay I'm
sorry I'm gonna run outside see what
this is all about I'll be right back
ladies and gentlemen I'm sorry get in
what why let me get it that's why
Oh shooting at you I assume Russian
mobsters shits Russian mobsters why
don't you call me out here so you can
help me out with this and I thought it
would be fun I don't shoot people that's
not what I do I'm sarcastic I have a dry
wit that's my face well you have to cone
him because I'm busy driving and also
browsing tinder it's real easy just
swipe right if you want a bang and left
if you think they're totally worthless
I know what tender is that use tinder
you have you're married yes how we hire
intern that's a lie Conan appropriate
I'm telling you what you don't talk to
my wife lawyer talks to my wife what do
I do with the guy Oh point that end at
the bad guys and just shoot what's just
the end where the bullets come out which
no not one that your finger don't shoot
yourself to the bullets come have you
ever seen a gun before movie do the
bullets come out of the hole or do I
love them through the hole oh my god
just pull the trigger
[Applause]
actually pretty good the guy that's a
sexual thrill right now aren't you glad
I got to come outside my god yes all do
I love to kill who no no you should have
called ahead there you go don't just
spring this on stop war hang on because
we're about again why are you even
driving they have apps now why would you
for using uber this is a really bad time
for a paid endorsement I'm not getting
any money from the uber people but it's
a fantastic app some Armenian driver he
comes by in a Prius the next thing you
know you're shooting with both hands
will you get your eyes on the prize
please don't worry buddy I got this they
should have a counter on the side old
VCR Sinead
[Applause]
Wow those guys really a lot of bullets
right I think I mean that no don't feel
like I'm done here don't do it that's my
thing you did it freezing it doesn't
even work there god I feel so alive how
do you stand feeling this awesome all
the time I'm always drunk I was not
trained for this I need an answer right
now Conan hurry up and figure it out we
go online we get tickets immediately on
Southwest Airlines then we fly to Boston
all right what toward Boston we make our
way in Winchester Mass my brother's got
a big basement it was recently renovated
we're not even paying rent it's a sweet
deal or you could just use this grenade
oh good it's good yeah give me the
grenade so I can get these guys off
mm-hmm crazily so I just pocus out it
explodes ha ha it's too up Conan and
stop with the phrasing you're killing me
that's not mature what you're doing okay
yeah close the damn grenade
Wow yeah incredible all right where's
your next where to next is back at your
studio
Judy Hill what whoa why because you
ruined my car Conan
let me stay let me hang with you you
look terrible get out I don't wanna chat
with celebrity I make me get out
[Applause]
sorry about that ladies and gentlemen
and by the way don't worry about this
it's not loaded
[Applause]
right back
you